For the first question,
I said that you should us an svg.
First off, vector graphics are nicer
because they can be scaled infinitely
unlike gifs, which are rasters.
And also, .svgs are actually smaller
than .gifs because you're using the same
image, and just animating its rotation.
Instead of delivering
multiple images for
the record at each point
throughout its rotation.
And for the second question,
it makes sense to keep it external,
with multiple videos all using this same
spinning record icon, it makes sense
that the browser should be able to cache
it and then use it on multiple pages.
All right, that's it for
the four scenarios,
it's time to jump back into the project.